all right so your keyhole was that
assumes a particular line
okay it's a particular mine
uh you're going from out of range to
within
range depending on what your
energy cue is so in this case you see
so if i bend my arm like this like this
uh he can hit me with the other do you
see so there's a there's a particular
range
and where continuity becomes viable
but then going past kataki
other things become but okay so
i i did this on my kotatsu dirty
then you can see i'm in another
viability range
the same thing can happen to him if he
bends his arm on katata dirty he comes
in
with a bent arm then you're gonna he's
it's viable if you see that
so he has to stay in the sweet spot of
cantata doni okay do you understand
all right okay the same thing goes on
here
um if i launch my attacks from out here
they're not viable i have to get
to that sweet spot where i launch my
attack so
it's going to be outside
of his lead weapons usually
so his lead jab so in other words
don't move if i launch my i walk in and
i launch my attack from
here you won't ever do it because
you're gonna get jab in the way in okay
or even the front kick could be front
inside thought
it could be groin kick same thing you're
walking oh boom and
done okay so i have to find this sweet
spot
because if i'm too far out nothing works
he just moves out of the way
he just moves out of him
so i'm learning my dynamic a dynamic
mind
katakuri is a static mod where is not
too close
not too far just right
well it's where that wrist grab becomes
viable
and other weapons have not yet become
so same thing here so i find my
that sweet spot you can't jab or
anything because
he would have to close the gap and then
boom i have the same
openings okay do you understand my first
objective
feel out where i'm here and then when i
get there
that's when i'll go poop to my face
what thing we want to work this graph we
want to work a guy
that is trying to stuff us trying to
hold on to us
okay so i get to there he could be
dancing around
it doesn't matter you're gonna see that
i get to there
get to that sweet spot and then come in
and then we want
him to work on his movement
his deviation okay
i'll do this drilling correctly that was
correct
so here i am he's not allowed to hit me
because he want
i want him to work on his movement so i
start milking that
as you can
that would not happen if i gave him back
his strength
or i go from here and i go
all you would have to do is take one
little
we're gonna do this all day he's just no
commitment
okay maybe i do a little bit of
commitment he deviates
that this part here was not my job my
job was to press
so he keeps working his deviation i'm
not finding him i'm training him
okay so i get to that spot and then i go
and i get him he has to be the one to
deviate
okay let's go
so starting static is beginner beginner
stuff okay beginner stuff
but out of the beginner training scar
you think it's he goes and i go
that's what happened he goes and i go
then you think you wait for him now this
doesn't work
this has no martial viability okay
it's just a a mechanical
puzzle this has no marshall viability
you don't wait for the attacker your
success goes way down
so uh once once you start going
that's more you're getting there he
might not even get the grab
once we start working at higher levels
of quinoa
nevertheless
[Music]
okay well the same thing here
so i'm not going to wait here until it
gets in that ring
and then i'm going to launch my text
your success goes way down
but in terms of what in terms of size
athleticism weight strength
it goes way down so maybe if i if i have
strength on him he goes
maybe i can get it but bigger stronger
i'm not gonna get it
okay in the same way that
he never really gets his grab
because i've already moved him he never
really gets his grab
i just matching his intention it's the
same thing here
as he goes in i was already matching his
intention
so he might get something it's much
easier
to now defend against that something
of a failure to him versus
your imaginary self-defense if then okay
so as he goes i'm already moving
i have to read his body already moving
move second is in his mind
i'm already off off that line whatever
you might get
is now lesser it's a lesser thing okay
i'm not doing this
i'm not doing that okay i can do the
same thing
as we move you see if
he didn't get a successful thing i still
got a knee kicking
okay all right try it again don't sit up
and wait
okay so we're micro drilling that rush
okay we're micro drilling that rush uh
if there's if there's no rashness he's
just coming in slowly right
oh and that that's yin energy
so your young energy has space to
operate
okay uh if he's if he's coming
coming really slowly again you could
just
he's never gonna get there okay
uh another thing to think about
um is after he does his
let's say he does this first one i'll
move out of the way
and now he goes slow again
same exact thing you see so you have to
train in hate this this attack
is is viable i get to the to my
range right
that is a viable attack
it's as viable as it's
say anything bible okay
this is not viable
darn it nor is
i do one you deviate and now i'm back
there again
we're gonna we're gonna hook you we're
gonna right hook you left pokey
okay so as you do your thing
uh treat it as a viable attack so you're
here
and you go you're not
half-assing it after they deviate
that's how you would address that okay
so
your attack is it's viable because
it's violence of action it preoccupies
him
uh even if even if he wanted to jab with
me running in
it doesn't do what it normal jab does
okay do you understand it gets jammed it
gets glanced
i'm still in i still got the body so
just make sure
after you do your bible that you're not
here because
the druid you killed the drill okay try
it again
okay and your
movements create patterns okay so like
last night's technique
he's coming in and we're gonna be here
and this is all spiral
movements are all spirals so
in your overall macro movement
it's not going to be straight lines i'm
not going to like this
it's not going to change
it's not going to be this way either
that's now a straight line so you go and
i go
this is straight line
five seven don't do what you think it's
going to do
okay so seven doesn't do it
i'm on a straight line that's why i see
me on announcements you have to get
yourself
near if not on the other side
of where he's at a macro level going to
start rotating
okay so as we as we go you see i'm over
here
then the fight's going to rotate you see
and it'll keep rotating with his energy
so if he continues
his movements it's going to keep i'm
going to keep it rotating
i'm going to avoid this
and i'm going to avoid these diagonals
and avoid these
this fight is always rotating rotating
rotating okay got it
okay let's bring the rotation in now
just as if he was
throwing a punch combination boom boom
okay i would not go like this
okay my hand my hands stay my hands stay
where they are
right my hands stay where they are so
the same thing
as he's going for this grab attack
i'm not going to like keep going i'm not
going like this
i don't move but does not have to move
okay
so he we're going he goes my hands don't
move
he goes my hands don't move if i don't
need to move them i don't move them
okay they're all always in an offensive
ready position
if you're clearing hands unnecessarily
they're not in an offensive position
okay so on that last one
if you feel it if he got a lot of lap
it was it's very tempting to knock it
off
you see but it'll come off with movement
and i get to keep my hands there okay so
reading
spiraling has no mood
okay let's try so i still happen
there's still no need and no advantage
to trying for a throw yet okay
start the flight rotating keep your
guard up
ready to go punish anybody that
goes too slow please any hidden space
punish them um
now there's something about the
centrifuge the spiraling geometry you're
going to generate a lot of centrifugal
energy
okay and i will use that
before i start clearing limbs okay
so we'll slow it down so he can kind of
get it right
so we're over here see he got it's a
pretty good hook you see and before i
start
clearing this limb or doing anything
with it
right i'm going to just keep using the
centrifugal energy
so we were going this way do you see
so i use that energy to get it going
if he gets an uh even a better group
i'll come on the inside a little bit
you see if the fight is going this way
right he thinks it's going to go this
way you see that that's what he's going
to do
but i'm not going to do that so his
energy goes like this
and i keep it spinning keep it spinning
and you'll see oh gradually they start
to loosen
they're losing their grip okay uh keep
that fight rotate
they will go all keep rotating
before you do anything i'm going around
rotating before you start dealing with
his limbs
okay try it again um
okay i still want to take away
the uh the advantages in his
offense okay um the next one is internal
this makes the world the difference okay
uh
so let's say he's we're gonna just
demonstrate it mechanically okay
so uh push push you see
and uh what we have to do now is
cause a deviation an external deviation
you see and he's gonna he's gonna push
and i'm gonna relax
lucy i'm gonna relax and he will not
have the ledge
that we usually give him because when
you push on what's pushing on you
you create friction that gives him the
leverage that he needs
okay then you have to understand the
psychology of what's going on
is when we go back in the drill what
happens is as
i feel his offense and i'm trying i
freak out and i start pushing back
and feel your feel your head clinch
watch what i'm doing to it
i just locked it in place
so as you go we might have to do this a
little bit more dynamically
i'm going to be very relaxed and i get
very slippery
okay as opposed to i go in attempts like
this
i have to relax we're going
you get slippery release
boom slippery slippery i feel
oh and my body wants to clench but my
training does release
and then he loses the hooks okay all
right so let's bring that in
okay if you look at your keyhole
you do that is your strategic concept
so if we take the technique again from
last night and i come around here you
see there's his balance you see
there's non-contestation and there's his
balance
and that's where i find the throat
i don't try that technique like this
see that that's not gonna work okay
so same way here a guy that's perfectly
balanced and he's coming in
you're not going to go and do your
coconut
you have to figure out how do i
dynamically
create all that disadvantage that kihon
already assumes is taking place okay
so these are the bare basics that i have
to do
when we took out the strikes to
specialize on these
basics okay the strikes do a lot
in this in this realm okay so
if we're gonna we'll see where it'll
come up because if you get really good
at that
this next part you don't even have to do
the throws
but that's where we would do the throws
okay
so i'll i'll screw it up
okay so he's going he keeps going
he keeps going keeps going and that's
that's where i find kaiten nugget
you see at that point
as opposed to i could not get here
naga is not going to work there okay
and continue is not going to work either
let's let's do it again give me a high
one
okay not gonna work
it's not gonna work you get his body in
position
as you're going you see see it
we go same thing go
keep turning it like you see it watch do
it again
turn me turning turn it right here
okay that's where you'll find python
okay so
you're going to do the same drills
relaxing
go spiraling loose and it's his
aggression that keeps it up and instead
of flexing
and muscling yield
kazushi pattern project
but the whole time i'm trying not to do
not to do it
okay
you